last night the Trump campaign put out an
ad that has a lot of people in an uproar
the ad compares Syrian refugees to
skittles here's the ad is the actual ad
they put out if I had a bowl of skittles
and I told you just three would kill you
would you take a handful that's our
Syrian refugee problem now a lot of
people were upset by that ad the Trump
campaigned though this is amazing they
doubled down they released a bunch of
other candy related ads today
check these out look at this one if I
had a 3 Musketeers bar and one of the
Musketeers wanted to marry one of the
other Musketeers would you still put
those Musketeers in your mouth that's
one unbelievable yeah look at this one
Reese's peanut butter cups the great
taste of chocolate and peanut butter
combined into one which goes against the
laws of God and yeah and there's this
one so let me get this straight
Razzles are a candy and then there are
gum so which is it Razzles because you
can't be both so stay out of our lady's
restaurant
Razzles
[Applause]
here's one oreo cookies are great but
the first thing we do is break them
apart and get the white the hell out of
them and finally and finally it's Adam
and Eve not Mike and I
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
you